the forum covers a very comprehensive
aspects of what the world is today that
is why new models must be based upon the
collaboration of the experience and
tradition of the past and what we are
going to do for a future there is to say
I do hope more more countries and
regions especially people common people
can share and care each other in
different kinds of aspects that is why
we are coming down here my specialty is
in the international training lots of
people talking about two very dull
around however I believe Doha round no
matter it is successful or not still
leaves us with a very rich experience of
the of the past decade that is to say
negotiation is something never to fear
about the only thing for the fear is
fear itself